Про стан Одеського художнього музею
наукова співробітниця Ненсі Калашнікова у своїх екскурсія не розповідає.
Втім, варто лиш запитати, як за останні 1,5 року змінився музей, одразу веде в 14 виставковий зал.
Це був справжній біль для музейників: протікала стеля і вода нівечила твори мистецтва.
Тепер це все в минулому.
Чудове освітлення, зверніть увагу на стіни. Все змінилось на краще.
На початку 2018 року конкурс на посаду директора Одеського художнього музею
виграв художник Олександр Ройтбурд.
За процедурою, згідно з законом “Про культуру”,
його кандидатуру одразу мали б затвердити депутати обласної ради.
Не підтримати могли б лише тоді, якби кандидат надав неправдиві відомості,
був судимим, або якщо б під час голосування сталися порушення.
Нічого подібного доведено не було. Та депутати його не підтримали.
Вони були зобов'язані автоматично затвердити мене.
Вони не затверджували мене, бо я їм не подобаюсь. Вони мені не подобаються.
Але це ж не є об’єктом регуляці законів України:
хто кому має подобається.
Є процедур, з точки зори процедури я є легітимним директором.
Юридичну процедуру завершив тодішній голова Одеської облдержадміністрації Максим Степанов,
який підписав контракт з художником.
Роман Сеник - один з депутатів, які виступають проти такого рішення.
На початку вересня він разом з іншими п'ятдесятьма депутатами
голосував за звільнення Ройтбурда.
У нього – чимало претензій до директора музею.
Були організовані концерти, які, м’яко кажучи, не відповідаюють рівню Одеського худоднього музею.
Справа в тому, що...
А який рівень Одеського художнього музею?
Це класичний музей, а коли там виступають майже голі хлопці
і співають пісні з нецензурноюю лексикою, нам здається, що це не те місце, де це має відбуватись.
Очевидно Роман Сеник мав на увазі виступ гурту "Хамерман Знищує Віруси».
Творчість Олександра Ройтбурда для малознайомих з мистецтвом українців
може видаватись скандальною.
Відомий у світі художник на своїх картинах зображує оголені людські тіла, геніталії.
За це переважно у проросійських ЗМІ його називають “порнографічним” художником.
Проте він - один із найуспішніших та найвідоміших на Заході сучасних художників України.
Для прихильників "Опозиційного блоку" в Одесі
він є нугодним ще й тому, що публічно підтримував Євромайдан.
А трагічні події в Одесі 2 травня 2014 року називав “днем, що врятував країну”.
Це не може бути причиною, це і є в тому числі частиною причин,
однією з причин, чому ми виступаємо проти нього.
Якщо ти політик, то йди займайся політикою.
Втім саме після тих подій масові сепаратистські і проросійські виступи в Одесі припинились.
Тепер одесити виходяять на мітинг в підтримку директора художнього музею.
Кількість небайдужих здивувала та приємно вразила організаторку заходу,
журналістку Анну Філімонову.
Також вона - авторка петиції до президента з проханням поновити Ройтбурда на посаді директора.
Це страшенно несправделиво і не можна на це не реагувати.
Є факти, і вони кажуть, що музей став локацією популярною.
Музей стали більше відвідувати, не тече дах.
Є багато показників, з якими важко сперечатись.
І коли опонети намагаються перевести все в площину своїх власних інтересів,
чи особистого ставлення до Олександра Ройтбурда, чи до його картин - це абсурд.
Це не може бути критерієм.
Ройтбурд як і раніше щодня приходить на роботу в музей.
Наказу про його звільнення ще немає,
а лише після наказу він зможе почати процудуру оскарження звільненя в суді.
Таку позицію підтримують й одесити. Вони вважють рішення депутатів політичним піаром.
Не знаю кому він перейшов дорогу і з якою політичною ціллю його з  прибирають,
але музей при цьому директорі ожив і відродився.
Музеї бідні, в держави грошей мало, в містах теж, і якщо людина може притягнути гроші зі сторони,
щоб цей музей ожив, розвивався і процітав, тоді він на своєму місці.
Нехай це питання вирішують працівники мистецтва, депутати далекі від культури.
Мені здається, це рішення невірне.
За півтора року роботи Ройтбурда дохід музею зріс удвічі та складає майже два мільйони гривень.
А завдяки започаткованій ним традиції меценатської підтримки
музей отримав додатково ще понад 3 мільйони гривень.
Вони пішли на реставрацію картин, купівлю музейного скла та ремонт залів.
В результаті – люди нарешті почали ходити в музей, його відвідуваність зростає,
а новаторська діяльність Ройтбурда зробила цей заклад
одним з небагатьох сучасних культурних просторів в Україні –
і точно єдиним у південній частині держави.
Візій, як зробити музей сучасним і цікавим для глядача, ще чимало.
І за наступні 3 роки, відведені контрактом, Олександр Ройтбурд планує їх втілити.